[Musique]
la tortilla de maïs l'aliment de base de
la cuisine mexicaine est en pleine
évolution fait à l'origine de farine de
maïs ou de blé on en trouve aujourd'hui
de toutes les sortes le marché de la
tortilla explose
en eau du ghetto on a dû sans gluten
dans le duo élevée en protéines on ne du
réduit en glucides en eau du élevée en
fibres alimentaires en avec du chou
fleur avec du coco avec des amendes d'un
des tortures de fromage
beaucoup d'imagination dans la catégorie
des tortillas
les fabricants suivent les tendances des
régimes alimentaires mais aussi des
intolérances et des allergies on trouve
même des produits sans farine comme ces
tortillas de légumes
épinards courgettes cross etc seulement
des légumes là dedans il ya pas de
farine c'est vraiment juste avoir des
légumes je pense que d'un point de vue
goût couleurs et tout ça ça peut être
intéressant il y en a quelques-uns qui
pique ma curiosité je désirais ceux à
base de légumes que je serai vraiment
intéressant goûter puis aussi ceux à
base de fromage parce que c'est
intrigant
on a demandé à la nutritionniste
stéphanie côté d'analyser l'offre de
tortillas comme elle l'avait fait il ya
six ans toujours dans le cadre de
l'émission l'épicerie afin de découvrir
quelles sont les nouveautés je ne
remarque pas qu'on s'en va vers la
naturalité avec les tortillas les listes
d'ingrédients sont encore très longue
même parfois quand il ya des légumes
plus souvent une poutre de légumes qui
se retrouvent dans les ingrédients après
le sel le sucre puis la poudre à pâte
donc en infime quantité
parfois il ya même pas de cet aliment
l'oeil juste d'écolo rapide la saveur
d'un côté naturalité l'on va repasser
pour plusieurs cela dit il y a une très
très grande différence entre les marques
il faut vraiment regarder les petits
caractères pour savoir ce qu'on achète
certains produits sont donc très
transformé avec beaucoup d'additifs des
agents de conservation des huiles pour
la texture comme l'huile de palme
l'huile végétale la plus utilisée mais
aussi la plus controversée pour deux
raisons la première c'est qu'elle
contient beaucoup de gras saturés qui en
excès augmente le risque de maladies
cardiovasculaires mais la deuxième
raison c'est l'impact de sa production
sur l'environnement ce qui fait qu'on
aime peau se la voir dans les produits
et pourtant les tortillas elle se
retrouve très très souvent
il y a des torts et à ceux qui
s'affichent sans gluten comme celle ci
fait à base de riz j'ai l'impression que
c'est très friable très cassants je sais
pas comment on peut vraiment faire un
sandwich avec succès sans gluten pour
les personnes qui ont la maladie
coeliaque par exemple ça peut devenir
intéressante
toujours dans les nouveautés des
produits quito pour diminuer les
glucides de son alimentation ou encore
des tortillas protéine est faite de pois
chiches ou de soya les ingrédients qui
enrichissent et double la quantité de
protéines du pain les protéines depuis
quelques années on l'aimé vraiment sous
le spotlight les protéines sont
importantes on succède à prendre des
repas plus rassasiant donc je pense que
les fabricants profiter de cette aura
pour en ajouter ça devient un petit peu
un avantage marketing par rapport à
d'autres les tortillas varie de 25 à 100
grammes chacune jusqu'à 600 mg de sodium
pour une tortilla et ce sans la
garniture on peut comparer démarquant
près des saveurs en réelles pour essayer
de choisir la teneur en sodium la plus
basse je vous invite à découvrir les
tortillas de maïs ce sont les plus
simples presque pas d'additif presque
pas de sel c'est intéressant de revenir
aux sources tortillas mexique
à sherbrooke dans ce petit local on se
retrouve rapidement comme au mexique
dans cette fabrique de tortillas
ces entorses et julie se spécialise dans
la fabrication de tortillas à base de
grains de maïs la partie géré ya ceux
comme un bol en boulangerie pour le
mexicain la tortilla c'est comme le
vague et pour le français
[Musique]
roberto et sa femme carla sont arrivés
ici au pays il y à 13 ans mais une
saveur du mexique leur manquait toujours
qu'il nous manque plutôt de nos pays
c'était bien sûr la famille mais aussi
la nourriture mais nous on voulait avoir
la traditionnelle torti gens dont on
fait tout le processus d'externalisation
complètes
la mixtes amm alisation consiste à cuire
et laissez tremper les grains de maïs
entier dans de louer delachoux comme
nous l'expliquent moyenne à ceux ci de
roberto donc la main ont fait leur
retour à la base avec les produits nokia
sion seulement trouées ingrédients on a
les maïs l'eau est un modèle important
de la shoah alimentaire donc on respecte
vraiment on est allé dans la tradition
donc on est allé dans la fabrication des
tortillas comme il se faisait par les
mayas et par les aztèques qui a 1000
1500 ans
une fois cuit les grains sont broyés
pour en faire une pâte fraîche que l'on
appelle massa on façonne il suffit de
cuir pour faire les tortillas légaux
c'est un peu le libérer guru maïs il ya
des gens qui passent par ici des forces
dit on se sent comme les peuples parce
que c'est vraiment ce
procédé qui conserve les propriétés du
grain de maïs pendant que se poursuit la
cuisson des tortillas stéphanie elle
poursuit son analyse et fait quelques
dégustations
comme ces tortillas de fromage vingt
cinq gouttes fromage sur sa route le bon
parmigiano reggiano
mais c'est goûteux fromage est quand
même intéressant
afin de mieux choisir stéphanie
préconisent les tortillas degré entier
et même la nouveauté de grains germés
pour ajouter des fibres à notre
alimentation saluc ne pas gober entier
on est vraiment leur poids juste blé
entier mecs on aime le lit moment les
pins le bas intégral on y est on est là
la serial good quelque chose
james e
ça c'est le résultat final de là tout le
processus qui est roberto et bojan
bousso expliqué tantôt taiwanaise chan
avec les grandes et minces la texture la
consistance légaux c'est complètement
différent
on choisit selon nos goûts et nos
préférences cet aliment qui permet
surtout de partager un bon repas
[Musique]